Speaker 1: We're learning more details about
the Colorado Springs, Mass shooting that
took place at an LGBT nightclub on November
19th. And much of the conversation has been
surrounding the shooter's motivations because
it's being investigated as a hate crime. And on
top of this being just a horribly tragic act,
there's also this political component to it,
this culture war component to it, because of
all the different issues that this overlaps
with. It's not just gun safety. It's also right
wing media, stochastic terrorism, LGBT rights and
all these other issues. And so that's why there
has been a lot of attention to this shooting in
particular and also just sort of the updates as
to what we know about it this time. It's maybe
more necessary to discuss the motivations of the
shooter than in other cases because it overlaps
with all these different issues. There's also the
concern that this specific type of mass shooting
could happen in the future because the right
is responding to it by stoking the fire there,
fearmongering even more about gender affirming
care, for example. Here's Tucker Carlson doing
just that on his Fox News propaganda show.
Speaker 3: So these horrifying murders in
Colorado over the weekend quickly became a pretext
for yet more censorship of your speech. You are
responsible for this. They told you because
you said the wrong things. You are guilty of
stochastic terrorism, inspiring violence by
your beliefs. Innocently, Aldridge committed
mass murder because you complained about the
sexualizing of children. Every time you object
to drag time story hour for fifth graders or
point out that genital mutilation is being
committed on minors, which it is every time you
say that you are putting people's lives at risk.
Speaker 1: So, Tucker, here talking about the
sexualizing of children and genital mutilation
to rile up his audience. Essentially, he acts
like his audience is being under attack by these
people who think that there are right wing media
hosts who are stochastic terrorists. And also this
has to do with free speech somehow really well
done in terms of propaganda by Tucker Carlson,
but not great in terms of lowering the temperature
right now, especially after a mass shooting, when
we don't want to see this type of thing happen
ever again. And then as we discussed last week,
there are other voices on the right who are taking
the path of victim blaming in terms of responding
to this. Here's Daily Wire commentator Matt
Walsh saying that, oh, well, people should just
stop dressing up in drag. I guess if you want to
avoid mass shootings at nightclubs and this sort
of thing, let's take another listen to that.
Speaker 3: But why should we be the only ones
explaining? Instead of asking why we oppose it
so much, we should ask why they supported so much
that according to them, they will keep doing it at
the risk of life and limb. Why is it so important
to you to cross-dress in front of children? Why
is it so important? Why do you need to do it? Why?
Is it worth the cost that you claim you're paying
for it? Why do you have to do this? Why can't you
just not do it? How is that without the effect
if it is really causing all this chaos again,
that's your version. I don't agree with that.
You're exaggerating. But according to you,
that's what you're saying. But is it? Why?
Speaker 1: Look, if only you didn't wear
that dress in public, you wouldn't have been
catcalled. That's basically the type of logic
that Matt Walsh is applying here. He's blaming
the victim. This is also coming from supposedly
someone who is pro-freedom. He's so pro-freedom,
I guess, that he doesn't want people to feel
empowered to live their life the way that they
want to live without risk of getting shot at by
people who irrationally hate them. Now to add
another layer of complexity to this story, it
was found out that late last week the perpetrator
has told their attorneys that they are non-binary
and immediately right wingers ran with this
story saying that, look, were vindicated. The
right had nothing to do with this. The shooter
was actually a member of the LGBT community,
so therefore it can't be right wing stochastic
terrorism that led to this. When really there's
a possibility that this person could just be
trolling and they're only now coming out as
non-binary when they lived their entire life as a
male. And they're doing so either to avoid a hate
crime prosecution or to just troll and make a
point to a right wing audience. We just don't know
the the facts of it yet. But still, that hasn't
stopped people like Tucker Carlson from going out
there and saying, look, we're vindicated. This
proves that there was nothing to be upset with
the right about. And let's take a look at it.
Speaker 3: You remember when Brandy Zadrozny
told you several hundred times that the accused
shooter, Anderson Lee Aldrich, was inspired
by hatred for the binary community that he
learned on this show? Do you remember that?
Well, actually, it turns out we discovered last
night that Anderson Lee Aldrich is drum roll,
please. Part of the non-binary community. He
doesn't hate them. He is one. In a court filing,
Aldrich's lawyers wrote this, quote, Anderson
Aldrich is nonbinary. They use they them pronouns.
And for the purposes of all formal filings will
be addressed as. Aldrich makes Aldrich. That's the
shooter. The non-binary shooter. Let that sink in.
Speaker 1: So look at Tucker Carlson. They're just
believing this thing, whole cloth saying that, oh,
yeah, the shooter could not have been a right wing
person trying to commit an anti LGBT hate crime
because they themselves identify as non-binary.
Now, I'm not going to discount the possibility
that this person legitimately is non-binary,
but it all seems very convenient that we're
only hearing about this now from the person
after they've committed this horrible act and
now that they're being investigated for potential
hate crimes like this could easily just be the
person trolling and trying to get a rise out of
these types of figures like Tucker and play into
the culture war. And you better believe that.
It turns out if it turns out that this is a hoax
and this person really never was nonbinary, does
not actually identify this way, Will Tucker won't
really have all that much egg on his face because
he just won't talk about this ever again. That's
what we normally see happen with these types of
things. And they can also just act as if like,
Oh, well, this makes the left look bad anyway,
because see how messed up it is that anyone can
just say that they are non-binary or just say
that they're a man or say that they're a woman
and everyone else has to believe them. Even
though that's not, strictly speaking, what the
left's position is. It's if you give a legitimate
effort to live a certain way or another, then
you should be respected as whoever you identify
as. But it doesn't mean that you can shoot a
bunch of people at a nightclub and then all
of a sudden claim that you're non-binary and then
everyone has to believe you at your word. I mean,
clearly you can be skeptical about that sort
of thing, but that's the latest on the right
wing in their reaction to this Colorado Springs
shooting. They are blaming the victims. They're
saying more horrible things about gender affirming
care. They're talking about how the left wants to
sexualize children. And they're claiming that,
oh, we actually don't have anything to worry
about on our side, because clearly this person
was part of the LGBT community. Just absolutely
despicable what has been coming from the right
on this issue in the past couple of weeks.